Dirty Harry directs a movie about the
afterlife hereafter so hereafter is
ultimately three movies it's three
stories and one it's about a little boy
who loses his twin brother it's about a
French journalist who's had an afterlife
experience yeah French journalist which
means French subtitles which means get
ready to read really fast and Matt Damon
who plays a medium which is someone who
can commune with the dead you know like
the Ghost Whisperer which we watch for
the stories both of them and the most
interesting story arc in this movie is
by far Matt Damon's I mean I really like
Matt Damon's character I mean through
the first half of the movie especially I
was just counting the minutes until he
came back on screen I really like how
his abilities kept him from having
normal interactions and relationships
with people that's awesome and by the
end of the movie I did like the French
woman's story and how it touched on if
you've had an afterlife experience I
mean you you can't really tell anyone
about it because they'll think you're a
freak and they'll think you're crazy now
what really bogged down the story for me
I'm sorry to say is the kid I mean he's
a cute kid and all but he doesn't matter
as much as the other to do however roads
don't start crossing in the movie until
like two hours and 15 minutes into this
two-and-a-half-hour movie so the
connections you do get with the
characters it's not enough not for me I
just can't help but think in my own dick
kind of way if the kid was phantom
edited out of the movie the movie would
have been about an hour and 45 minutes
long and I wouldn't have gotten the
Return of the King feat you know in
Return of the King after they dropped
the ring in and there's still like a
half an hour left in the movie and you
start just being like come on and I did
that in this movie I call it The Return
of the King feat I love Return of the
King I wouldn't have it any other way
but the fact is by the end of the movie
you start getting edgy but you've also
had two and a half hours that were a
little worth it so I just expected more
from this movie I expected more
intricacy with three storylines dealing
with the afterlife directed by Clint
Eastwood I mean to be fair I suppose if
you've had an afterlife experience of
some sort you'll connect with this movie
like to an insane degree and power to
you I just haven't I haven't died which
just goes to show you you have to kill
yourself to connect with hereafter don't
kill yourself I'm just saying I mean it
was well acted the dialogue between the
characters was really well-written
conceptually it looked good and had
things about it had good potential but
in reality it's okay but you're not
gonna remember it in t-minus 13 hours
sadly get off my lawn just saying it
looks pissed about that great premise
though and kind of a shame but if you
like what you're seeing here and you
want to see more than click right here
to see more